yeah you did a great job and i you know
in seeing the movie i hadn't seen a lot
of the scenes that you did as the
butcher and you're scary
and you're also badass
[Applause]
hi i'm chris landon i'm vince vaughn and
i'm kathryn newton and we're going to
break down some of the scenes from our
movie
ricky
where the hell did you learn how to do
that
dad was an eagle scout found these
this is actually one of the rare and few
scenes in the movie where
all of our characters are actually
together in one place
millie is trying to convince booker that
she is
not the butcher that she's millie that
she's stuck inside his body
and it's this great comedic beat because
the butcher
is now using this body that he's in
to play a role to play this sort of like
innocent victim and don't believe him
we've got vince kind of stuck in this
really tricky spot where
you know he's he's trying to convince
booker of something that's
clearly impossible vince you just killed
the scene
i remember because you you you just went
he was vince was improvising
and that's why the scene is so good you
just went off
do you remember i remember playing
around with it but i also remember
how kind of like mean you were i
remember like i did this whole like
vulnerable
speech and you kind of humiliated me and
called me a name
and you did it in such such a kind of
cruel like really cruel
way don't you remember that of course i
remember that
he's even gorgeous when he's unconscious
hey jesus easy easy easy it's okay
it's okay look i know i look like the
butcher but it's melly
this is gonna sound really strange
booker
booger look at me he's crazy okay booker
can you look at me please
please booker please can you look at me
just for a second
the way you use your hands in this
i'm like i don't know is it is it
insulting is that how i talk is that
what i do
no i think it's like that thing you kind
of get grounded and committed to the
characters and then when you're
listening and trying to actively get
someone to listen
it just sort of comes out yeah so i
think it was more kind of the stuff that
we worked on and talked about
and then you're just in that moment
you're like really trying to get this
this guy that you like not to freak out
and to pay attention and
go urgent with it okay so last night our
consciousness
or our spirit whatever you want to call
it okay it traded places
she's telling the truth so he stabbed me
with the dola which is like this ancient
mystical
dagger and now i have like less than six
hours to swap back or i'm gonna be stuck
in his body forever
vince really improvises um quite a bit
in this scene
it works on so many different levels
because he's
both showing how millie is is
nervous and afraid um and desperate to
convince this kid of who she is but also
like
she's facing her crush and it's one of
my favorite scenes in the movie because
i feel like everyone has has their
moment and the scene
starts out in this place that's sort of
a little bit mysterious then it kind of
veers into something that's a bit more
comedic
in tone but then it actually pivots into
something that is
more serious because millie finally
figures out
a way to convince booker um
that she's really stuck in this body but
in doing so she has to reveal something
that's a little bit embarrassing about
herself
it was really the three of us i think we
just found we talked
internally what was going on and finding
you know back stories that we were
sharing and then it became about finding
physical manifestations of things that
the characters would do that
that came from an internal place um and
so we kind of had a common
language that we sort of tried to get
unconscious with so that as you're
listening and playing in scenes you just
sort of
would react you know in character i mean
the rehearsal in the beginning it just
made me feel really confident that on
the day
i knew my butcher was going to be
vince's butcher like just just having
like a little bit of rehearsal
and having like one thing to kind of
ground yourself whether it's like my
posture
or the way i run when i'm millie and
just those little things like that make
you
really confident that we're gonna have a
a seamless
switch when we go back and forth you're
all
going to jail for this you too booker
unless you help me
booger try a [ __ ]
were you shut up i got so inspired
like watching you i think the end when i
was like
booker booker please please and started
being like a teenage girl
i don't know i just i just really went
for it yeah you did a great job and i
you know in seeing the movie i hadn't
seen a lot of the scenes that you did as
the butcher and you're scary
and you're also badass you know what's
interesting and fun about this movie is
that you know
both actors have to play two roles and
so
when we were creating the butcher
um michael kennedy my writing partner on
this movie
um we both wanted to create sort of like
the ultimate sort of like killing
machine
and you know we really wanted to reach
back to the 80s
you know and reference a lot of the the
classic slasher
films that we both sort of have grown up
watching and have loved
our inspiration of course drew was drawn
from you know halloween and michael
myers and
and jason voorhees um but we also wanted
to
make our own iconic killer and so the
butcher you know
is is that classic silent
um killing machine and then for millie
you know we wanted millie to sort of be
a modern final girl in the sense that
um that she has a really defined
character arc
you know when we meet her she's shy
she's introverted
she's unsure of herself and over the
course of the movie by inhabiting
somebody else's body she really starts
to discover who she really
is which is kind of the fun of the swap
so that by the time she
hopefully gets back into her body um
she's
she's a more confident more sort of
fully realized authentic person
look i know this is crazy okay there's a
lot of voices competing
you see my friends you know nyla and
jocelyn they're on my side okay and this
is clearly not me have you ever seen me
dress like that i mean i
kind of like a lot of what he's doing
with it but
it's the point is that you've never seen
me dress like that right do you like
that
it doesn't matter i feel like i'm giving
you a lot of information and you
literally just woke up
you look great i think the key to
balancing comedy and horror
is to make sure that you're using
something to ground
both of those elements to unify them and
so i mean i really just look to the
characters
um first because if we are engaged and
invested in
in the character from the beginning of
the movie then i think we can kind of
ride those different tones um a little
bit more freely because you just want to
see what happens
to to these people um and so that's
usually sort of like the first way to
unify
the two i'm just a big fan of of mashing
up genres
and it's and it's not for everyone some
people don't like their horror and their
comedy mixed together but i've always
loved it
um and so for me it just feels very
comfortable
to to put the two of those together
whoa what am i wearing
[Music]
if you get recognized we are screwed i
can't say [ __ ]
how do killers do this sorry oh that's
your face okay head over to fandango for
more on our new movie freaky
[Music]
you